an alert security officer at a Southern
California High School is being hailed
as a hero for thwarting an apparent
shooting plot police arrested a 17 year
old student at El Camino High School
after the security officer said that he
heard the teen say that he was planning
to shoot up the school authorities then
found handguns two rifles and in in
ninety high-capacity magazines at the
teens home just 90 joining us now from
LA is that alert security officer Moreno
Chavez and here in studio with me is Jim
Hanson a former member of the US Army
Special Forces and now president of the
security studies group it is so great to
see you
Marino tell us about what happened I
mean you are just being hailed as a hero
today given what happened last week in
parkland
how did you have the foresight and tell
our audience what occurred well it's a
Friday afternoon that El Camino High
School and the bell rang after lunch so
I'm watching all students going back to
class I'm walking around and then I
overhear a students state that watch
there's going to be a shooting on this
campus so I got just part of the what he
had said so they're not walked up there
and question him again ask him okay what
exactly did you say and then of course
he's denying it
so I scored him to the office questioned
him I called assistant director to the
office I call the counselor and
questioning question and he finally
admits it they said yes I said I
guarantee you within three weeks
there'll be a school shooting he was I'm
just kidding I don't mean nothing about
it so then I asked them I don't know I
tell them you can't say that just like
you can't say bomb on a plane because
you'll be squirted off the plane right
and so then then the authorities went to
his house they found all those weapons
right so I called the sheriff's
department they came down talked to him
investigated they took him into custody
and they checked the home and they found
the weapons why are they not identified
by the way they haven't identified him
by name is there a reason for that oh
because he's a minor he's under 18 years
so it could be charged by the you know
minor he's 17 years old and it recharged
as an adult in a plot to perhaps blow up
the school to be looking at a social
media Jim I gotta ask you about this I
mean the heat Marino did what the FBI
did not do when they had actually seen
these comments on YouTube and then of
course got the tip at the FBI line so a
security officer at a school hears it
and says wow this is not right
which is why armed security at schools
is a great idea the argument against it
is absurd the idea that somehow this
does not help is crazy now whether or
not the guy in Parkland failed in his
duty for whatever reason to protect
those kids that doesn't invalidate the
concept you know there's a saying a
famous saying from the Wild West God
created men Samuel Colt made them equal
with the peacemaker well the left has
made one crazy with a gun more equal
because now they're the only one who's
armed on too many campuses and we need
to change that now Marino the school the
El Camino is a small school certainly
compared to Parkland as 200 students
compared to 3,000 are you an armed
security officer or unarmed I'm an
unarmed and there's about two hundred
and sixty five students approximate okay
so you're you you are armed or unarmed
sorry I couldn't hear that no I am NOT
armed I got it out with everything
except a gun no ma'am okay no we are not
armed would you prefer to be armed or
you're not comfortable with that no I
used to be an armed officer before I
started with the school district yes arm
would be better I can do more for the
school district because if they're
shooting in the campus right yeah what
are you supposed to do if someone gets
into the building
I mean you stop you you prevented a
school shooting I mean I'm sorry I'm
gonna say it people say well he might
have no you prevented a school shooting
what would have happened if that kid
who's for some reason were not not
identifying because he's a snowflake so
what if he had gotten a gun and gotten
in that what he supposed to do throw
their throw things at him what the heck
is supposed to do ridiculous you do what
ball coach okay all right and you run at
an armed gunman right who's your own
body as armored
okay so that's what Torino is supposed
to do you know that the teachers and the
parents and frankly the students if
they're not indoctrinated by CNN or
other other organizations at be they
have someone like you who knows how to
use a firearm the president said that
today people who know how to use
firearms who are adept and confident in
their use should be armed at a school do
you agree with him I agree a lot with
them because a lot of officers have the
training so they're the ones that should
be armed should be standing outside and
the quiet in the front of campus showing
off the uniform showing that we are not
an easy victim that we will shoot back
if you come in attack a student on
campus well I want Moreno arms not with
this great mind just that was good but
we want you also armed with with a
firearm Jim and merino thank you so much
what a great panel